it's disgusting to see
uh people you know put into such a
horrible situation the fear that's been
created
uh it's so unfair to asian new yorkers
we know where it started
we know very painfully it started in
washington dc
oh my god now we know the details of
that heinous beatdown of an elderly
asian woman
de blasio looks like an even bigger
idiot than before
but the lessons learned from this are
bigger than that of a failed politician
like him
this brutal attack is indicative of the
failures
of progressive policy first the suspect
in this case shouldn't have been on the
streets in the first place
he was somehow paroled in 2019 despite
the fact that he stabbed his own mother
to death back in 2002
every parolee every parole for violent
felons
is a hallmark of the new left not the
right
the second lesson doesn't relate to the
man who committed this violent attack
but the men
who stood by and watched it happen now
many of the same people outraged that
the bystanders did nothing
are the same ones who are forever
protesting this idea of toxic
masculinity okay it turns out that when
you reduce men to pathetic
and shamed beings they act like pathetic
and shamed beings joining us now tucker
carlson host of tucker carlson tonight
as well as tucker carlson today
on fox nation tucker can i do your
voiceover i want to do
tucker carlson today can i do that i
think you'd be better at than i am
i'm not a voice over jesus i'm so glad
you said that about toxic masculinity
and then when you reduce
people to husks to fearful husks that
they behave that way
you're exactly right someone should have
grabbed that guy and stopped the assault
or held him
for cops but nobody did because people
are afraid to intervene i mean this is
what happens when you strip people
of their ability to defend themselves or
defend others
it's really and i think tucker part of
it is like snitches get stitches
too like if you if you turn in some
other guys in certain parts of certain
neighborhoods
then you could get yourself in trouble
or get arrested if you do something
wrong i think everybody
is living in fear of getting sued
running foul of
of the authorities or being called a
racist or
worse if there's anything worse than
that everybody's afraid
no that's totally right and too afraid
to say what everyone knows which is de
blasio's explanation of this is just a
it's a galling lie
it's absurd he doesn't believe it he's
lived in a city for 30 years anyone
who's lived in the city knows exactly
what's going on
this is not new it didn't start with the
last administration or the preceding 10
administrations
this was the basis of the 1992 riots in
los angeles
al sharpton made a career for decades
intimidating and threatening asian
business owners i mean
this is a very well trod path we know
exactly what this is about
i think the tensions are primarily
economic but they're also cultural
and to blame this on white supremacy or
trump it's like it's insane and nobody
stands up to say that everybody who
lives in the city knows what this
is everybody does now i want to get your
thoughts tucker on something that
kind of flew a little bit under the
radar today it's a rather
telling comment from secretary of state
tony blinken
we're not trying to for example contain
china
or keep it down what we are about is
standing
up for basic principles
basic rights and a rules-based
international order
tucker your thoughts on that uh posture
with china i mean you know have you been
to caribbean recently or africa i mean
china is colonizing
the entire third world southeast asia i
mean these are all
functionally economic satellites of
mainland china
we've ignored this i mean the entire
road system in
i don't know pick a place saint croix is
paid for by the chinese the bahamas
you know china has been completely
uncontained and there's probably no
containing it now but you'd think
someone should acknowledge this i mean
if you're against colonialism
and our universities teach us that we
have to be against colonialism why is no
one noticing
chinese colonialism which is just
galloping across the globe totally
unimpeded by anybody including the joke
of a secretary of state the failed rock
star
tony blinken who's speaking of craven
speaking of weak husks
that would be tony blinken did you see
him kind of shaking
when chyna's delegation just like looked
at him and said you know
basically you guys are systemically
racist why are we going to listen to you
you guys don't even like yourself
he's like shaking he didn't seem to uh
he didn't say he's like mommy
mommy come get me now no when they're
reading blm talking points
against him and he's like you're right i
mean look
they're not stupid they don't hate
themselves they know that our leaders do
hate themselves and hate the country
they represent and try and lead
and they use that to their advantage why
wouldn't they i mean if you were trying
you know to maintain hegemony over a lot
of the world you would use your
opponent's weaknesses against him it's
basic judo and the fact that our leaders
don't even
see this as happening the racism thing
is such kryptonite to them
no wonder the chinese you can't kind of
blame the chinese for this can you i'd
do the same thing
if i was in a negotiation oh you're
racist okay
[Laughter]
hey tucker i want to move to your new
show on fox nation
tucker carlson today now you had a a
really cool
interview with um michael moss who
is this whoever doesn't know him he's
his pulitzer prize winning
journalist uh and he and he's written a
lot on addicting
foods watch yes so the people
engineering marketing positioning these
products
don't eat their own products either
because they know better health-wise
or they're concerned about losing
control
i think that's one of the difficult
aspects of this is kind of knowing
who's vulnerable to overeating these
products and when and how can they
how can they deal with that well don't
we see the same thing tucker with the
big tech ceos who
many of them strictly limit their own
kids scream time but they're happy to
saturate our kids with it that's exactly
right the country's really unhealthy it
has nothing to do with kovid
i'm not lecturing anyone i've certainly
gained and lost hundreds of pounds over
the years i love
fig newtons to my great detriment i like
crappy food i always have i probably
always will so i know firsthand
that there is a compulsive part
of the experience of eating these kinds
of foods like you eat an apple you don't
feel like eating six more apples you eat
an oreo you'll eat the whole bag why is
that because these foods have been
engineered by big companies to make them
addictive
in the same way that tobacco products
were which by the way i also enjoyed i'm
not judging anyone i'm just noting
this is a huge story it's transforming
the country physically
and everyone is ignoring it and i'm not
sure why we shouldn't ignore it's a big
deal
if you get type 2 diabetes at 35 like
that's not a small thing for
anybody so why are we pretending it's
not happening it is happening and people
are getting rich from it
and tucker finally do you think the
fouchy
berks public health expert
media medical cartel do you think it's
kind of over that people
are beginning to see what this really
was
i think the whole thing is over i think
the whole facade is just shattered like
nobody
if you don't believe the lies then you
don't believe any of the lies
i mean that's why we did a segment like
that because people all of a sudden are
realizing wait a second maybe everything
they're telling me is
is not on the level maybe the food
pyramid's wrong which of course it is
and so i actually don't think they're
convincing anybody they're just trying
to make people obey just read the
catechism
here's the bumper sticker recited or
else they're not trying to make a case
for rational people to buy into like
we're way past that
tucker congrats on the new show we will
be watching
and it's great to have you on the ingram
angle and don't forget sign up
for fox nation now and yeah and you get
to
get this plus you get exclusive access
to other original content
events your favorite personalities like
tucker on any device so use the promo
code tucker
you get a 30 day free trial tucker
you better come back soon
done laura ingram i'm monitoring thank
you
all right great to see you tonight